翻訳: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
校正: Hiroko Kawano
私が初めてTEDに出会ったのは
TEDxSapporoChange
というイベントでした
2012年の4月のことです
当時 登壇者の浅田一憲さんの紹介で
TEDxのステージに立つので観に来ないか
と言われたことがきっかけでした
その当時の私は TEDのことも知らなければ
TEDxのことも知らない
そんな状態でとにかく観に行きました
そうしたところ 18分という
熱のこもったスピーチ
それから アメリカから配信されてくる映像
MCの方も英語でスピーチをするなど
見たこともない世界が
そこには広がってました
私もすごく影響され
なんてカッコいいんだ TEDは！
なんていう風に思ってました
そして私は すぐに
その当時のオーガナイザーの
ディリップ・BK・シュナールさんの所に行き
私もスタッフをやってみたいんです
そんな風に伝えました
その当時 TEDの「Ideas worth spreading」
それについて私は
何の疑いを持つこともなく
かっこいい！ と思ってました
とにかくミーハーだったんです
なので 私はそのことを
何の疑いもせず
よし！価値あるアイデアをを広げていこう！
そんな風に思ってました
でも今は きちんと
そのアイディアを広める理由を持っています
今日はその理由について
皆さんと共有していきたいと思います
私が アイデアを広めるのは
アイデアを広めると
自分自身が成長すると思っています
さらに その先には
より良い世界が待っている
そんな風に
繋がっていくであろうと思っています
さて
では 話はTEDxSapporoSalon
に行ったときの話に戻っていきます
私が初めてイベントに参加してから
毎月イベントが開催されていました
その中で 私は参加をして
そして マット・カッツの
「30日チャレンジ」に出会いました
「なるほど」 と
マット・カッツさんは
自分の普段からやりたいと思っている事を
30日間始めてみよう
という風に問いかけてたんですね
私もすごく
おぉ なんてすごいことなんだろう
って思いました
でも その次の
さらに１ヶ月のイベントまで私は何もせず
次のイベントを楽しみにしているだけでした
ところが近藤章さんは
30日チャレンジを実際に実現して
それを話してるんです
へぇ！
実際にやる人いるんだ
なんて思いました
その当時の僕は
そんなに行動力の高い方ではなかったので
参加するぐらいが関の山で
これを実際にやってみよう！
なんてところまでは
全く行き着いてなかったんですね
なので それを見て私も影響され
30日チャレンジを始めてみることにしました
実際に私が行ったのは
プログラミングのアイデア
30個の企画を考えました
そして TEDに影響されていたので
それを英語で書いてみました
もちろん30日達成したからといって
アプリが30個新しくできたわけでもないし
英語がすごい得意になったわけでもないです
でも その当時の私にとって
30日間何かを続けられるというのは
自分自身にとってすごく自信につながりました
だって 毎日何が起こるかわかんないんです
30日の間には
例えば 飲み会に誘われたりとか
おこってしまうわけです
毎日毎日これのために１時間 ２時間
時間を使ってしまわなきゃいけない
でも そうとは限らない
でも予測ができると
早起きしてそれをやろうとか
ちょっとずつ自分の行動が変わっていく
そんな体験が
今の自分にはつながっていると思います
その後のイベントでですね
スピーチをする機会も頂いて
なんとなくディリップと僕の距離が
縮まってきたなって思っていました
４カ月経って やっと私は
TEDxSapporoのスタッフに
入れてもらうことができました
そのときは本当にうれしかったです
４カ月もかかっちゃったんですよ
そして私はスタッフになって
テックチームと言われる
パソコンの操作ですとか
それからこういった会場を作る
そういうお手伝いをしたりですとか
ありとあらゆるまぁ 泥臭い仕事を
沢山してきました
その中で少し経ち少し経ち やっと
スピーカーと話をする立場になったりとか
やっとパートナーさんと
話をする立場になったりですとか
少しずつ自分の経験の輪を
広げていくことができました
そうして2014年の
TEDActiveに参加しないか？
とディリップに声をかけられました
その当時の僕は
まだまだ英語ができなかったので
行くのか・・・
行きたくないな・・・
そんな行きたくない理由ばかりを考えてました
Activeは３月にあったので
会社も年度末で忙しいなぁ
あっちまで行くのにすごくお金かかるじゃん
そんな風に
行かない理由を考えてたんですけど
でも心の底ではなんか行ってみたいんだよな
なんていう風に悩んでいたら
ある時に アドバイスを頂いたんですけれども
そんなチャンスめったにないよ
私は 何か
そういうチャンスに巡り合った時は
チャレンジしてみる方を選ぶよ
そんなアドバイスを頂いたんです
直接 行けとは
言われたわけではないんですけども
そのことがきっかけで
私はTEDActiveに行ってみることにしました
TEDActiveに行くと
そこはオーガナイザー達の
世界中のオーガナイザー達の集まるところで
すごくやる気もあって
活発に議論がかわされ
私もその中で一人 英語もできないし
自分はまだオーガナイザーじゃないし
すごくしょぼくれてました
でもそんなある時
事件が起こってしまったんです
それは鞄の中に
パスポートやお財布を入れていたんですけども
その鞄を忘れてしまう
という事をしてしまったんです
必死になって探したんですけど無いんです
仕方がないので スタッフの方
ホテルの方 セキュリティーの方
いろんな方に身ぶり手ぶりで
説明するしかないんですね
そうすると何時間か経って
鞄は見つかりました
そのままの形で
私はそこで 必死になれば
ちょっとコミュニケーションとれるんだ
そんなふうに思いました
それからというもの 沢山の仲間が
できたわけではないんですけれども
少しだけ 何人かの方とは
お話することができて
ま ちょっとだけTEDの輪の中に参加できた
そんな様な気がしました
そこで出会ったオーガナイザー達
日本のオーガナイザー達とは特に
仲良くなることができて
各地のイベントにも
参加するような機会も頂きました
日本に戻ってきてTEDxSapporo 2014
その中で私は
TEDActiveの中で
学んだことを生かしたいと思いました
TEDActiveで学んだ事の一番の学びは
トークとトークの間の時間の使い方です
すなわち
スピーカーの話を聞いたり トークを観たり
ただ傍観しているだけではなくて
そのあと交流をするんです
隣の人と話をする
それからアクティビティに出て
アクティビティの中で隣の人と会話をする
何か行動を促すような そんなことが
TEDActiveの中では行われているんです
ワークショップもその一つかもしれません
そのアイデアを活かすために
戻ってきてすぐにディリップに
いゃ僕 アクティビティやりたいんだけど
そんなふうに話してみました
そうすると周りのスタッフも
いいね！と言ってくれて
アクティビティを７つほど考えました
その一つが
マット・カッツの30日チャレンジの
オープンマイクというものです
どういうものかと言うと
イベントの約１か月前から
30日チャレンジを沢山の人を集めてして
そして TEDxイベントの日に皆んなで
マイクを握って
僕 30日間こんなことやりました
みたいな事を発表する
そういうイベントを作りました
そうしたところ
まぁ 当然 私は
その当時Co-organizer（副代表）になったので
何かやらなきゃいけない
やってみよう！と思ったんですけれども
私が普段からやりたいと思ってきて
できなかったこと 何か？
それは 毎日一生懸命仕事をして
一生懸命 TEDxのことをして
そして 帰って 寝て 起きて
またすぐ仕事に行く
そんな生活ばっかりしていたので
うちの妻とは全くコミュニケーションが
取れてなかったんです
なので これはいい機会だと思って
私は「コーヒーコミュニケーション」
というのを行ってみることにしました
30日間 毎日朝１時間ぐらい早く起きて
コーヒーを淹れて
そしてコーヒーを
妻と一緒に団欒しながら飲む
そして夫婦の会話を少しだけでもする
そんな日がTEDxSapporoの開催する
30日間続けていました
そうすると何が起こったか
当然 SNS上で皆さんで交流をしていたので
その夫婦の会話を赤裸々に書くわけですね
うちの妻にも
当日ボランティアを手伝ってもらっていたので
まぁ途中で
ボランティアに行くの嫌になってきた
なんてことも言われたりとかするんですね
でも最終的には
当然 30日では終わらないよね？
31杯目もあるんだよね？
みたいな感じで仲良くなっていき
もちろん36杯ほどのコーヒーを淹れ続けました
そうしてTEDxSapporoのイベントを無事
うまく迎えることができたんですけれども
イベント終了後にディリップが
母国ネパールに帰るということになりました
私はディリップから
次の代表は君だ！
というような形で任命されて
自信に満ちあふれてました
だって
スピーカーさんとのやりとりも
できるようになってたし
パートナーさんとのやりとりも
すべてのことを知っている
そんな自信があったんです
でも 実際にやってみると
不思議なことが起こりました
TEDとは何か？TEDxとは何か？
TEDxSapporoとは何か？
そういった説明はマニュアルのように
上手にできたんですけれども
価値あるアイデアってなんだろうか？
うまく説明できないんです
スピーカーさんのもとへ行って
価値あるアイデアを話してください
なんていう風に言ったら
おかしいですよね？
あなたのアイデアを聞かせてください
とは言っても
価値あるアイデアを聞かせてください
と言うわけにはいかないんです
でも このステージで話されることは
価値あるアイデアを話す
そんな機会なんですね
そうして改めてビジョナリーな
ディリップの凄さに気づいたんですけれども
私自身何をしたか？
TEDActiveで知り合った
各地のオーガナイザーの下へ
沢山のイベントに参加しに行って
オーガナイザー達と交流させて頂きました
自分の持ってる考え
それをぶつけたんですね
そして TEDトークも観たり
こうやってイベントに参加して
生で話を聞いたり
そんなことを繰り返すうちに
やっと自分の中で少しずつ
腑に落ちてきた事があるんです
それは
いいプレゼンテーション
いいアイデア
必ずしも等しくはなくて
ここで話されるべきことは
いいアイデア
すばらしいアイデアなんだと
決して
スライドが綺麗とか
流暢に話をするとか
そこではなく 本質的には
どんなアイデアを話すか
そこが大切なんだ
ということに気がつきました
よく アイデアマンという言葉があります
アイデアマンとは
どんなものか
一つは
そうですね 発想が豊か
もう一つは
問題解決能力が高い
そんなことがあるかと思います
では 私は沢山のTEDトークを観たり
沢山のTEDxイベントに参加して
アイデアマンになったのか？
と言うと
自分自身 全くそんな気がしませんでした
では 私がTEDxから
学んだものは何だったんだろう？
それは 行動するきっかけ
それを頂いたことです
ですから私たちTEDxSapporoは
価値あるアイデアを 行動のきっかけを
行動するきっかけをもたらすもの
そう位置づけています
やっと腑に落ちたんです
では 行動とは何か？
行動には３つのレベルがあると思っています
１つは知るレベル
もう１つは理解するレベル
そして３つ目は広めるレベルです
知るレベルというのは
まず 沢山のTEDトークを観たり
こういうTEDxのイベントに参加をして
まず 素晴らしいアイデアに触れる
そんな人がいるんだっていう 人を知る
そんなことがあるかと思います
でも実際に扉を開けて家に帰ったら
さぁ 家に帰ったらやってみよう
自分も同じ事をしてみようと思うと
何が起こるか？
例えばTEDxSapporoの中では
キャンディ・チャンの「Before I die...」
という動画を観て
その動画を真似て 札幌の地下歩行空間で
「Before I die...」
のイベントをやってみることにしました
実際にやってみようとしてみると
知っているはずなのに できない 分からない
ということが起こったんです
そうして何度も何度も動画を観て
議論を交わし
やっと できるようになったんです
細かいことを言うと
いやこのボードどのくらいのサイズで
作ったらいいんだろうか？
世界標準はどのくらいなのか？
この文字と文字の間隔はどうしたら？
とかですね
調べないと分からないことが沢山あったんです
なので 知ったつもりになってても
きちんと理解していない
ということが起こったんですね
少し行動してみて
やっと理解できたんです
なので 私たちは何度も何度も調べる
その中で自分たちが知る
ということを深く知る
ということが起こりました
そして３つ目は
広めるということです
自分が理解した事を
隣の人に話をする
そうすると
自分自身が理解していないことに
気づいてしまうんです
なぜなら うまく説明ができないからです
そこには 自分自身の中で
思い込みというのが発生していて
自分の中では そうだ！
って思ってるんですね
ですから隣の人や知人に話をしてみる
そうすると初めて自分の思い込みに
気づくことができるんですね
考えの違いがあるからでしょう
ですから 周りの人に
自分が知っているアイデアを話してみる
広めてみるというのは
非常に自分の理解を深める為には
効果的なんです
そういう意味で
この３つの行動という風に位置付けています
価値あるアイデアを広めていく
それは
その過程で自分の中の思い込みが打破され
そして考えも整理整頓され
自分の成長につながると思います
みんな一人一人が成長していって
さらにそのアイディアが
その過程で広まっていければ
世界はよりよい方向に
向かっていくと思います
今までは自分の専門分野の
知識だけを入れたくて
自分の知っていることに
近いことをたくさん観ていたかもしれません
でも 自分と全く違う分野の話にも
そういうアイデアは
キラリと光るようなアイデアがあるはずです
ですから皆さんも先入観にとらわれず
色んなTEDの動画を
観て頂きたいなと思います
アイデアを広めるその一歩を
歩み出してみてください
そして 自分が持っているアイデアを
皆さんに広めていってみてください
次のスピーカーはあなたかもしれません
ありがとうございます
（拍手）